-My first guest is an Emmy-
and Oscar-nominated actor.
You can see her
in the highly anticipated
new movie "Wonder Woman 1984,"
which will be in select theaters
and IMAX Christmas Day,
and it will be available
the same day on HBO Max.
She is also hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend,
with musical guest Dua Lipa.
Please welcome Kristen Wiig!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Kristen Wiig,
nice to meet ya ♪
♪ We're gonna see you
play the Cheetah ♪
♪ Kristen Wiig-cha,
nice to meetcha ♪
♪ You can watch at home
or in theaters ♪
♪ Kristen Wiig,
nice to meet ya ♪
-Look at that -- Kristen Wiig!
Come on.
-Oh, my God.
-You look fantastic.
I miss seeing you.
I'm so thankful,
and I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy to be here.
-You look great, bud.
I want to get into "SNL"
and everything.
I just want to say thank you for
helping us out over the summer.
We did the sketch called
"The Longest Days of Our Lives."
-That was so fun.
-I laughed so hard
just even filming --
just filming it.
Nancy, by the way,
who clearly loves you,
didn't even get a chance
to even say hi.
But she was seeing everything.
I wasn't.
She was holding the iPad this
way, so she was going like...
[ Laughing ]
And you and Will were going --
[ Both laugh ]
You and Will were --
-It was so fun.
Needed it, yeah.
-It was fantastic.
And I love that
you had your own wigs.
-Well, I have a costume wig...
-Box?
-It's a big box, yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
Well, you never know when you're
gonna need, like, a wig.
[ Laughter ]
A funny costume.
-That's true.
-Yeah, our friend's daughter
had a birthday,
and we did, like, a drive-by,
and we're like,
"Well, we should probably wear
wigs and costumes."
-Even though
they didn't ask you at all?
-They didn't ask us.
-No, of course not.
Yeah, but you wore them.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You're hosting "SNL" this week.
It's the Christmas episode.
It's my favorite episode
of the year.
-It's my favorite.
My favorite probably
was when you hosted --
It was the first time you
hosted, I think?
The Christmas show.
-Yeah. Yeah, that's right.
That was, like,
one of my favorite --
-Where we all danced?
-Yes, the monologue
where we all danced
around the studio.
-Oh, man.
Wasn't that so much fun?
And it was snowing.
-It was so fun.
-Fake snow was coming down.
[ Laughter ]
-Tiny little bits of plastic.
-Yeah.
-Before any sketch.
-And we're like, "Ahh."
[ Laughter ]
-Before any sketches.
Before "SNL,"
I think I know a little bit
about your background.
Groundlings before that?
Were you in plays?
Were you doing --
-Um...
I mean, I did, like, a couple
school plays but in the chorus.
-Okay.
-Like, the people that audition
that don't get the parts,
then those were the parts --
That's what I did.
-You did that?
-I did the chorus parts.
-And were you good at that?
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
No.
But it was like --
It was "Anything Goes,"
so I was like --
I, like, danced and tapped.
I had never tap-danced before.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't have phones back then.
-They didn't even
ask you to tap.
You're like, "I got this."
-[ Laughs ]
I know, exactly.
I just tapped across the stage
in the middle of a scene.
Yeah, I remember my mom
came to see the play,
and I waved to her
from the thing.
-Aww.
-Yeah, and she's like,
you're not --
-So cute.
-Yeah, but no,
I wasn't like 8 years old.
This was, like, high school.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Waving at your mom?
-No, I was, like,
fully in high school.
-"Hey, Mom!" -- Your voice
was even deeper back then.
-Waah!
[ Laughter ]
-Look at you now.
Now you're in
"Wonder Woman 1984."
-It's crazy.
-Wait.
I want to hear everything
about this.
-Yeah, I still --
Like, I just wanted to come out
because I feel like
it didn't happen.
It's like a dream.
-Right?
You were in a major
superhero movie.
Like, this is major.
I'm so excited.
What was it like?
Did you do, like,
the workouts all day?
-Yeah, no, I know.
It was -- It was --
I mean,
I knew I would have to train,
'cause I started training
before I left.
They got me a trainer like
a month before,
and it was like, you know,
train for like an hour,
like, then you're good,
and then I got there,
and it was like --
-Special weights and...?
-Oh, no, it was like --
Oh, you train for hour,
and then, you have stunt
choreography for four hours,
and then you have lunch,
and then you have
a movement class,
and then, like --
-Really?
-Yeah, it was very, um...
intense.
-It's work, man.
-No, it was great.
It was amazing.
-How did you get involved
with this?
Did you know they wanted you
for the sequel?
-I g-- I guess, like,
Patty, yeah, she reached out
to my --
My agent called me and said,
"You know, Patty Jenkins
wants to talk to you."
And I was like, "Yeah."
-It's awesome.
-I was like, "Yes.
Could this be
the 'Wonder Woman' sequel?"
So they didn't know.
Like, my agents didn't know,
and I wasn't allowed
to tell them anything.
-After the meeting?
-Yeah, I had to sign something
before I even, like,
talked to anyone.
And I am a nerd.
Like, I take that stuff
really seriously.
-Yeah, you could get arrested.
-I was like, "I can't tell you.
It's a part, but I am not
allowed to tell you what it is."
-And you're doing this
while you're driving,
not even looking at the road.
-Yes, yes.
-"And I can't tell you
where it is, and, uh --"
"Look at the road, Kristen!
Look at the road!
You're driving."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-That's wild.
So then, you met with her,
and she said,
"We'd like you for this?"
-Well, I had to go do, like,
a screen-test reading thing
in London.
So I had to, like,
fly to London.
And even my friends, I'm like,
"I'm going to London.
I can't discuss anything.
I can't tell you why I'm going."
-"Kristen, you're on a Jet-ski!"
"I guess I can't
say anything -- Whoa!"
[ Laughter ]
-I get paranoid
that the Warner Bros. police
are gonna...
-Are gonna arrest you.
-Yeah, were gonna arrest me.
-Who do you play in the movie?
What can we say
without spoiling anything?
-I'm so scared.
-I know.
Am I allowed to say anything?
-I'm playing Cheetah.
-I mean, first of all,
I love Cheetah, by the way.
I think it's perfect.
I love it.
-She starts off very
as Diana's friend.
-Yep.
-And she's very shy and awkward,
and then, later becomes --
-Yeah, that's all you can say.
I don't want to --
Look at you.
You're really good.
You're freaki--
You're crying blood.
[ Laughter ]
I don't want
to ruin anything, either,
so don't say any more.
Dude, you do
crazy stunts and action.
Like, I don't even know
what's you in there.
I know you as Kristen Wiig.
I mean, you're so funny,
and you're just awesome in
everything, I just love you.
But this was a totally --
Like, dude, you kick butt
in this, you and Wonder Woman.
Oh, it's fantastic.
-It was really fun.
-Do you know how to do stunts
now and stuff?
-I mean, we --
There was a lot of, like --
Yeah, there was
a lot of training.
I mean, I'm not like --
-If I name a stunt,
could you tell me what it is?
-Oh, sure.
-How about deck the halls?
-Yep...that --
that --
that is a lot of arms.
-Yep.
2/3 Nelson?
-Oh, boy, that's an oldie.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
How about the --
the lobster punch?
-The lobster punch.
That's only been done
a couple times.
-Well, this is amazing stuff,
for anyone watching.
-Yeah, the lobster punch
is hard.
It's more of a claw action.
-Than a punch? Oh.
-Than a punch.
Well, it's, like, together.
So it's really hard.
That's why they rarely do it.
-They described it well then,
yeah.
A lobster punch.
The Chattanooga Choo-Choo?
-Oh, yeah.
From the '30s.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, really? The 1930s?
♪♪
-Oh, wait.
You sneak up on your opponent
like this.
[ Both laugh ]
-You square up to your opponent,
and you tap-dance --
-And you hit them on the head
with a tambourine.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, I don't know.
-I want to show everyone
a clip from the movie.
Here is Kristen Wiig
in "Wonder Woman 1984."
Take a look at this.
-Do you know that song?
-No, no.
-Hey, Jake.
Jake, hi, can you...
-I had a convertible.
Anyway...
-Hi. [ Chuckles ]
I know, walk much?
The latch of my --
Oh.
♪♪
-Good morning.
-Hi.
Thank you.
-Diana Prince, cultural
anthropology and archaeology.
-Barbara Minerva,
geology, gemology, lithology,
and part-time cryptozoologist.
-Oh, wow.
-Kept busy in college.
Sorry.
It's these heels, you know.
I -- Just stupid.
I don't know why
I was gonna wear heels.
Scientists don't wear heels.
-Sometimes we do.
-Right.
Right.
-Have a nice day.
-Those are cool.
I like those, the animal print.
Rarr.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh!
Aaah!
-"Wonder Woman 1984"
will be in select theaters
and IMAX on Christmas Day!
What a Christmas present.
And will be available
at the same day on HBO Max.